considera la siguiente tabla de valores
para una función lineal fx es igual a mx
más b es la pendiente y ve la
intersección con el eje de la siesta y
una función exponencial gdx es igual a a
por r elevado a la equis y bueno justo
aquí tengo la tabla pero no podemos
trabajar aquí así que déjame sacar
nuestro bloc de notas o nuestro pizarrón
como lo que es ver que no tengo justo
aquí y ya tengo aquí el problema así que
vamos a trabajarlo lo primero que me
piden y déjenme tomarlo con este color
cuando este de aquí es una función
lineal
efe es igual a mx más p f x es mx más
ven y me dicen que para x igual a 0 1 2
3 4 5 tengo los siguientes valores de fx
que bueno justo que me dicen que es mx
más bien así que qué te parece si
trabajamos en primer lugar con esta
función lineal y bueno lo primero que se
me ocurre y por lo que yo estoy muy
feliz es que tenemos el valor en x igual
a cero tenemos que en x igual a cero
esta función lineal
de un medio vale un medio así que eso lo
voy a utilizar y dice efe de 0
efe de 0 aunque cuando x vale 0 esto es
lo mismo que utilizando la definición de
esta función bueno pues es m x 0 m x 0 +
b
ok y esto es igual a un medio es justo
lo que me está la tabla cuando x vale 0
f x vale un medio es lo mismo que un
medio ok pero yo estoy muy feliz porque
este datos nos los dan porque de una
manera muy sencilla podemos obtener el
valor de bent m por 0 pues esto es 0 y
solamente me queda que ven b es igual a
un medio a un medio y de lujo ya tengo
el valor de b
si nosotros queremos obtener el valor de
fx ya estamos muy cerca de encontrar
nuestra función ahora puedo escribir a
fx y dejamos ponerlo con color rojo
fx ya lo puedo ver de la siguiente
manera como m como m por x + b pero me
vale 1
más un medio ok ahora podemos trabajar
con el siguiente punto
aquí está vamos a trabajar con el
siguiente punto con este de aquí y lo
voy a sustituir en esta función de aquí
para ver si así puede ya encontrar de
una manera muy rápida la pendiente la m
es decir que f1 a f1 me están diciendo
que es lo mismo que 3 pero si utilizamos
la definición de la función esto es lo
mismo que m que multiplica x pero en
este caso x vale 1 m por uno más b pero
b vale un medio ok y yo sé que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 3 porque porque
justo esto es lo que me dice la tabla
recuerda que la tabla es muy importante
para encontrar estas dos funciones
me dicen que cuando x vale 1 f x vale 3
entonces esto es lo mismo que 3 de lujo
y si ahora nos fijamos en esta parte de
aquí voy a poder despejar a m m
un medio más un medio es igual a 3 ok o
dicho de otra manera m es lo mismo que 3
menos un medio ok y de aquí puedo
obtener que m es igual a 6 medios menos
medio cinco medios cinco medios ok
cinco medios más un medio me dan seis
medios lo cual es 3 de lugo ya tengo el
valor de la m ya también tengo el valor
de v así que puedo sustituirlos en mi
función
fx ya tengo de manera explícita el valor
de fx
y déjenme ponerlo aquí fx fx es igual a
la pendiente pero la pendiente vale
cinco medios de reponerlo con su
respectivo color a cinco medios ok que
multiplica a x déjame ponerlo con este
color que multiplica x + ven pero ven
sabemos que vale un medio entonces a
esto le sumamos un
de lujo ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo con
gdx vamos a utilizar toda la información
que podamos para obtener cuál es la
función g de x y si te das cuenta aquí
en esta función exponencial lo que
necesitamos saber es cuánto vale a y
cuánto vale r tras lo que vamos es los
valores de amd y los valores de r donde
eres la base por cierto y de igual
manera voy a utilizar esta tabla y para
utilizar esta tabla que te parece si
utilizamos el valor de x igual a 0s creo
que siempre es muy importante y es
bastante útil así que qué te parece si
bajamos un poco en la pantalla vamos a
bajar un poco la pantalla solamente para
trabajar así con lo que nos resta de
esta información
vamos a trabajar ahora con estos dos
puntos de aquí y déjenme atraparlos con
este color con estos dos valores de aquí
y eso quiere decir que gtx vale 2 cuando
x vale 0 y gx vale 10 cuando x vale 1
así que utilicemos gtx y déjame poner
esta función con verde aquí gtx que es
lo que queremos es igual
por el ala x ok y ahora tengo kg de 0
y déjame cambiar de color puede utilizar
este color g de 0 es igual a a por el
elevado a la 0 estoy sustituyendo a x
por el valor de 0 g de cero es igual a a
por el acero y esto es igual según lo
que me dice la tabla a 2
esto es igual a 2 ahora lo padre de esto
es que era el acero es esto se van el
acero es uno recuerda que todo número
elevado de acero excepto el cero es un y
por lo tanto de aquí voy a obtener de
que voy a obtener que a por uno que es a
a es igual a dos de esta parte obtengo
que es igual a dos y ya tengo el valor
de amd entonces ahora puedo decir aplica
que me ponerlo aquí kg de x es igual a a
pero a vale 2 a 2 por ere elevado a la x
x r elevado
y ahora lo que necesito es el valor de r
y para sacar el valor de r vamos a
utilizar esta otra información que tengo
aquí déjenme cambiar de color voy a
utilizar esto de aquí y dice que g de
171 cuando x vale 1 gtx vale y vamos a
sustituir cdu no es lo mismo que 2 x r
elevado a la primera potencia ok
x vale 1 y esto es lo mismo que 10 según
lo que me dice la tabla esto es lo mismo
que 10 o dicho de otra manera y de aquí
vamos a poder obtener el valor de r
vamos a utilizar esta parte de aquí 2 x
r es relevado a la 1 es lo mismo que
erre esto es lo mismo que 10 o dicho
otra manera r vale 5 r vale 5 si divido
de ambos lados entre 2 y bueno ya tengo
el valor de amd ya tengo el valor de erc
que ajuste lo que quería
entonces nos podemos sustituir justo
aquí ya se queje de equis y déjame
ponerlo aquí a de x es igual
pero a vale 2 entonces lo voy a poner
con este color a 2 x r pero r vale 5 a 2
que multiplica a 5 elevado esto a la
potencia x elevado a la potencia x ya
tengo a fx ya tengo a gdx am y déjenme
subir un poco la pantalla para poderlos
poner en nuestra solución
ok lo voy a poner más o menos así de
lujo ya tengo a fx
ya tengo hdx vamos a ponerlos en la
página fx es igual a 5 medios por x más
un medio déjenme ver si me acuerdo haber
pongamos la página justo aquí a cinco
medios de x 5 a medios ok que multiplica
a x esto que multiplica a x ok y esto le
vamos a sumar le vamos a sumar un medio
me dio ok cinco medios de x más un medio
eso es lo que vale fx y bueno vamos a
ver cuánto vale gtx porque no tengo tan
buena memoria déjame poner aquí cinco
medios de climas un médium perfecto y
gente x es 2 por 5 elevado a la equis ok
vamos a ponerlo justo en esta página
ok 22 que multiplica ok a 55 elevado
este es elevado no éste nos sirve
perfecto 2 que multiplica 5 elevado a la
equis y vamos a comprobar la respuesta y
de lujo estamos bien ya aquí tenemos la
solución de este problema